well we are learning more now about the  terrifying moments that led up to an  officer-involved shooting near saharan  hualapai on sunday  metro says 40-year-old seth holliday's  psychiatrist  and his wife called 9-1-1 saying he was  trying to kill her  when officers arrived holliday was armed  with eight  kitchen knives and was stabbing his wife  sergeant douglas king who's seen in this  body cam video  told him to drop the weapon that's when  holliday said to shoot him and sergeant  king  opened fire holliday died there at the  house  his wife does have multiple stab wounds  but police say she's now stable  this is metro's 14th officer-involved  shooting this year